monsieur Vincent pourquoi ce serait une
bonne idée de repousser de deux ans
l'âge où les gens ont le droit d'avoir
les rangs du Québec on a sondé nos
membres vous savez la FCI c'est le plus
gros regroupement de PME au Canada c'est
55% qui sont favorables à cette
politique là le tiers à peu près avec
son compte parce que si on veut avoir
une bonne politique publique qu'il faut
l'adapter au contexte quand on le met en
application le programme des RQ dans les
années 60 l'âge pour accéder à la rente
c'était 65 ans l'espérance de vie
c'était 67,7 ans dans ce temps-là il y
avait 6 % des personnes de 65 ans et
plus qui 6% qui est dans l'ensemble de
la population est rendu à 21% puis on va
augmenter avec le temps on a modifié le
régime qu'on était capable de le faire
dans les années 80 pour donner de la
place à la génération montante d'avoir
accès au marché du travail donc si on va
avoir un bon programme public ben c'est
nécessaire de pas mettre cette idée là
dessus du tapis ok juste préciser je
donne la parole Magali Picard suite
après vous est-ce que c'est une façon
pour que les gens soient incités à
rester plus longtemps au travail mais il
y a plein de raisons parce que c'est bon
pour les bénéficiaires parce que ça va
permettre aux gens de pouvoir
travailler sur le marché du travail
parce que ça va assurer la pérennité du
régime je pense que c'est important de
pas de pas juste dire non puis de
repousser la décision pendant 6 ans puis
peut-être à ce moment-là on va avoir
encore moins de marge de manœuvre de
prendre la bonne décision vous dites les
gens vivent beaucoup plus vieux et là il
y a des proportions entre l'âge du début
de la retraite et le décès éventuel
Magalie Picard pourquoi vous êtes contre
qu'on explore ça
on est contre la FTQ puis je vais
commencer tout d'abord en vous disant
que en ce qu'on nous dit et ce qui est
écrit à l'intérieur du guide de
consultation du ministre Gérard c'est
deux choses on nous parle de bonifier le
régime des rentes du Québec alors que en
repoussant de 60 à 62 ans mais les
personnes qui devraient jusqu'à 62 ans
ne verrait absolument pas le régime
bonifié bien au contraire actuellement
on a un travailleur qui quitte à l'âge
de 60 ans a une pénalité de 36 %
lorsqu'il part en retraite anticipée à
60 ans s'il quittait dans un nouveau
programme là à 60 ans non seulement il y
aurait le 36 % des pénalités mais 500$
de pénalité supplémentaire parce qu'une
pénalité supplémentaire s'ajoute pour
les travailleurs qui prendraient leur
retraite encore une fois anticipé dans
le nouveau programme en 62 65
on va on va montrer un tableau tout de
suite parce que correspond pas à ma
compréhension mais vous allez me
corriger Magali Picard là si on prend
notre retraite on va le voir à 60 ans
par mois
c'est la moyenne c'est 836 dollars à 60
ans si on attend à 62 ans
c'est 1024 dollars à 65 ans c'est 1000
36 dollars si on attend 70 ans c'est
1855 autrement dit plus on attend plus à
chaque mois jusqu'à la reste de notre
vie on va voir plus vous vous dites
c'est pas tout à fait ça je vous
réécoute ce qui est à l'intérieur du
guide de consultation est très très
clair on a vraiment des spécialistes des
acteurs qui ont passé au travail ce que
ça dit c'est que oui on demande au
travailleur il y aurait une obligation
d'attendre à 62 ans et là on parle de
tous les travailleurs on parle des
travailleurs
parce que vous savez la bonification du
régime qui est proposée par le ministre
gérant va amener une lourdeur
supplémentaire au régime on va partir
d'actuellement là le régime coûte 12,39
% et avec la proposition on amènerait
une lourdeur supplémentaire à
12,55%, le poids qui sera amené serait
davantage important ce qui ferait en
sorte qu'on aurait une nouvelle
réduction à 62 ans jusqu'à 35 ans qui
ferait en sorte qu'un travailleur actuel
le chiffre pour ceux qui ont droit à la
plaine au Régie des rentes le plein
montant la Régie des rentes perdrait
jusqu'à 500 dollars par année dès la
première année à 62 ans
mais tant que Monsieur Vincent comment
vous avez compris mais je pense que
votre tableau est quand même assez clair
là je l'ai vu puis ça semble avoir un
effet positif puis je vous citerai trois
experts qui sont talents comme ça
parlementaire c'est à dire les trois
acteurs en chef de la Régie des rentes
du Québec qui ont été là le 1994
à 2011 ok ils ont donné leur vie à bâtir
un régime public pour les citoyens
québécois puis ont affirmé en commission
parlementaire que c'était 90% c'était
positif pour 90% des personnes visées
donc c'est pas des gens qui ont des
objectifs corporatifs qui ont donné leur
vie à la règle ce que je peux sur
l'argument parce que le ministre
contrairement à la France une autre
régime et pas en danger il est en
surplus ça va bien il y a de l'argent 3
milliards de profils moi je vais vous
dire Monsieur roi ce qui est caché
derrière tout ça là il y a un grand
débat moi je suis à peu près convaincu
que le ministre il repas de l'avant avec
le repos le rapport de l'âge de 60 à 62
ans même le Conseil du patronat est con
d'accord donc je comprends que Monsieur
Vincent représente la Fédération
canadienne des entreprises en dépendance
mais le conseil du prêtre Ronal lui dit
on devrait laisser libre choix on
devrait laisser le choix au travailleur
à 60 ans j'étais avec Monsieur Blackburn
à une rencontre cette semaine
je pense que c'est un faux débat
actuellement ne t'inquiétude à la FQ je
vous le dis là c'est le fameux mécanisme
qui est à l'intérieur du de la
proposition et où le ministre tout à
fait le contraire que justement son
actuaire en chef de La RQ je vous
explique le ministre je pose la question
maintenant Girard lors du dépôt du
mémoire est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rassurer que votre mécanisme n'est pas
de transformer le régime à prestation
déterminée vers un régime du style à
prestation cible le ministre Gérard dit
mais vous êtes deux trois à me parler de
ça on veut absolument pas changer le
régime pour un régime à prestation cible
ou monsieur Roy
l'impact de la cagnotte et de la caisse
de la régie de la référence serait sur
le dos des retraités au lieu d'être sur
le dos des employeurs et des cotisants
il me dit à n'est pas question c'est pas
ça le but du régime du changement et là
il demande à son actual de l'expliquer
et là tu vas en chef nous dit exactement
le contraire du ministre en disant
ok totalement monsieur Vincent sur le on
se recule un peu là pour que les gens
nous suivent sur le principe général
vous vous êtes il faut accepter de
réfléchir à l'âge on a le droit d'une
rente parce qu'on vit beaucoup plus
vieux les gens restent sur le marché du
travail puis on peut s'arranger pour
leur donner plus d'argent à chaque mois
c'est juste simple le faire monsieur roi
les années 60 on était 60% de notre
temps au travail après ça diminue ça
diminuer à chaque génération donc on est
moins longtemps au travail on vit mieux
on est plus en santé le marché du
travail
les employeurs ils sont il adaptent le
marché du travail pour les les aînés
puis il y a plusieurs pays qui vivent
des situations comme le Québec
je peux juste finir mon intervention
que je puisse donner je vous ai laissé
parler madame Picardie
l'Allemagne a pris ce virage là la Suède
le Danemark sont souvent des pays qui
sont donnés qui sont donnés par exemple
comme exemple par la partie syndicale il
y a juste ça de prendre la mer
j'aimerais bien qu'on parle au travers
de la construction à nos gens qui
travaillent à moins 40 sur les toitures
d'édifice nous poseurs de tapis de
céramique nos gens qui travaillent à la
salubrité nous préposés aux
bénéficiaires dans les soins de santé
allez donc voir ces gens-là quand on
parle d'espérance de vie on prend jamais
en compte les gens qui ont commencé les
travailleurs qui ont débuté à travailler
à 15 ans 15-16 ans qui ont travaillé dur
physiquement toute leur vie ces gens-là
n'ont pas la même expérience de vie
monsieur Vincent merci beaucoup claire
votre point de vue madame Picard très
clair aussi on est revenu sur nos rails
alors à très bientôt au revoir